كانت طائرة x-15 ، التي قفزت بسرعة تصل إلى أربعة آلاف ونصف
ميل في
الساعة وتسلق ارتفاعًا يصل إلى 67 ميلاً إلى
حافة
الفضاء ، لا تشبه أي طائرة أخرى
، وعلى الرغم من أنها استغرقت السماء منذ أكثر من
60 عامًا
باستثناء المركبات الفضائية ، فإنها تظل هي
أسرع طائرة مأهولة صنعت على الإطلاق
[موسيقى]
بدءًا من كسر حاجز الصوت
بواسطة x1 في عام 1947
، دفعت طائرات x التجريبية التابعة لوكالة ناسا
باستمرار حدود الاحتمال
ولكن ربما لم تدفع أيًا منها بقوة أكبر
من طائرة أمريكا الشمالية
x-15 التي تم تطويرها خلال الخمسينيات من القرن الماضي
تم تصميمه لاستكشاف رحلة تفوق سرعتها سرعة الصوت
بخمس مرات
ولإرساء الأساس لمهام لاحقة
في الفضاء للقيام
بذلك ، وقد تم تجهيزه بمحرك صاروخي ضخم xlr 99 بقوة
دفع 57000 رطل مع صمام خانق
ودوافع للتحكم  خارج
الغلاف الجوي للأرض
بوقود يدوم أقل من
دقيقتين ، تم حمل x-15 حتى 45000 قدم
تحت جناح قاذفة b-52
[موسيقى]
من هناك يمكن أن تطلق u  ع إلى
حافة الفضاء يبلغ ارتفاعه عشرة أضعاف ارتفاع
طائرة ركاب مبحرة
[موسيقى]
أو الطيران مباشرة للوصول إلى سرعات
قصوى تصل إلى ماخ
6.7 تقترب من سبعة أضعاف سرعة
الصوت ،
كانت x-15 سريعة جدًا لدرجة أنها لم
تضاعف الطيارين فقط  معدلات ضربات القلب
، أنتجت درجات حرارة على غلافها
الخارجي تتجاوز
1200 درجة فهرنهايت
والبيانات التي حصلت عليها من قرارات التصميم والهندسة المستنيرة
لبرنامج الفضاء الأمريكي حتى مكوك الفضاء ،
فقط 12 طيارًا متهورًا طاروا على الإطلاق
x-15
وذهب اثنان منهم  ليكونوا
رواد فضاء من النخبة ،
كان أحدهم هو جو إنجل والآخر كان نيل
أرمسترونج
باستخدام المهارات التي صقلوها في
قمرة القيادة في X-15 ،
وذهب إنجل لقيادة مكوك الفضاء
بينما تولى أرمسترونج قيادة
مهمة أبولو 11 إلى القمر
أرمسترونج و  طار زملاؤه من الطيارين
x-15 ما يقرب من 200 مرة
بين عامي 1959 و 68 ودفعوا
الحدود وأسروا المناجم بينما ذهبوا
كل هذا وأكثر مما أكد أن X-15
ستسجل في التاريخ
كواحدة من أعظم رحلات الطيران  آلات
صنعتها لك من أي وقت مضى